welcome students and friends especially
those
watching online my name is matt bell and
i'm the director of programs for
external affairs
here at the college i'm also responsible
for the students
paper grades so be nice to me
it's a privilege to open this second cca
of the academic year big tech
life has never been more convenient and
comfortable for most of the human race
and much of that is thanks to technology
libraries full of information have never
been more accessible
food can be ordered on a phone and
brought to your door in a matter of
minutes except for in hillsdale maybe
money can be transferred at the speed of
light and one can finish his or her
christmas shopping
in a matter of minutes including rapping
on the other hand in some novel senses
life has never been worse
as our institutions are crumbling
certain information
that which is deemed misinformation or
in violation of ever nebulous standards
is becoming harder and in many cases
impossible to find
george orwell's memory hall has become a
reality
our ability to communicate face to face
has faded even before
coronavirus hit us and the world is
interconnected in ways that has hurt
many of our fellow citizens
a brand new secular religion with new
layers of dogma being revealed each week
in tomes of community guidelines
has been forced upon us by those who
wish to control what we can say and do
they are increasingly successful in
their quest
opponents of this new religion are
silenced as heretics in the name
of so-called safety inclusion and
science
how should we think about this dichotomy
can power be rested back from google
facebook twitter amazon and others
can they be controlled at all by the
government and if so how
those are some of the questions we
addressed this week
i wish we were meeting under better
circumstances and i'm not just talking
about an election that is highly suspect
at best
as i speak this room is mostly empty due
to due to the mass hysteria propagated
by our media
and defended by the oligarchs in big
tech
some of the world's leading
epidemiologists for example uh
experts who have explained the virus
situation in a science-based
remedy clearly in their great barrington
declaration
they've been muted by big tech along
with millions of voices that need to be
heard in a free society
even if many of those voices are wrong
in a free society they must be allowed
to speak
our modern political discourse including
discourse about this pandemic is not
healthy
it is based much more in fear based on
fear than more on fear than facts
in michigan we have been waiting for our
elected representatives to challenge
empress whitmer's abuse of power for
months
and we are still waiting millions of
people in states across the country are
doing the same
in states controlled by both parties
the country and the world are in a tough
spot to put it lightly
but in many ways we have been in tougher
spots before
and some of the great statesmen and
citizens have shown us the way
through these times at hillsdale we aim
for such statesmanship
and we fight we will fight to the last
breath to continue our 176 year old
mission
of educating free citizens in the
liberal arts and defending civil and
religious liberty
and intelligent piety in the land
hosting this conference on this subject
at this time
is part of that effort so thank you for
being here
the student who will introduce our
speaker this afternoon is alex reiter
she's a junior from marlboro
massachusetts speaking of statesman
marlboro
studying english please welcome alex to
the podium
[Applause]
alan bukhari is the senior technology
correspondent at breitbart news
a graduate of the university of oxford
mr bakari is a 20
2020 lincoln fellow at the claremont
institute
for the study of statesmanship and
political philosophy
he has written for numerous publications
including tech crunch
real clear politics the post-millennial
and the jewish voice
in 2018 he obtained and published the
google tape
a recording of google's top executives
reacting to the 2016 trump election
and declaring their intention to make
the populist movement a blip
in history he also obtained the good
sensor
an internal google document admitting to
censorship
facebook's list of so-called hate agents
and youtube's search blacklists
he is the author of big tech's battle to
embrace the trump movement
and steal the election please help me
welcome mr bukhari
hello everyone thanks for coming
uh what is big tech what does that word
mean we use it very often
i'm going to start with the idea of big
tech in the most abstract sense of the
word
big tech as it exists today means
control
it is the antithesis of the original
ideal
of the world wide web which was
liberation
the liberation of information the
liberation of expression
the ideal behind the world wide web when
it was created in the 1990s
was that everyone could have a voice all
you had to do to access the global
marketplace of ideas
was to go online and set up a website
and that website belonged to you no one
could kick
you off because they didn't like what
you said that was also by design
because the web when it was invented was
competing with other types of online
services
that were not so free and open it's
important to remember that the world
wide web as we know it today
a network of websites accessed through
browsers
was not the first online service ever
created
in the 1990s tim berners-lee invented
the technology that underpins websites
and web browsers
creating the web as we know it today but
there were other online services some of
which predated berners-lee's invention
corporations like compuserve and prodigy
ran their own online networks in the
1990s
that were separate from the world wide
web and had access points
that were different to web browsers
unlike the decentralized world wide web
with its network of independent websites
compuserve and prodigy were privately
owned networks
they were open to the public but every
bit of information on those networks
was owned by them and they could of
course kick you off
for any reason the web was supposed to
be different
on the web you had almost total freedom
to set up a website or a web server
which then belonged to you unlike
compuserve and prodigy
there was no owner of the world wide web
who could kick you off
that was the idea anyway as we know this
is not the case today
the web today is very controlled and the
people who control it can kick you off
despite the noble ideas that animated
the early spirit of the web it was as we
now know
captured by a handful of corporations
we all know their names google facebook
twitter
youtube amazon just like those old
companies
they own everything you put on their
platforms it's their decision
to give you a voice or not
the web which was meant to liberate
information got us right back where we
started
unaccountable control over online
information
in the hands of a few powerful
corporations
if we want a way out of this mess we'll
have to find a way
to make the web better represent the
ideals of its founding
but we can't just think about it in
abstract and historical terms
very few people used online services in
the 1990s whether it was tim
berners-lee's world wide web or
compuserve
but everyone uses them today you can't
not use them
businesses depend on them news
publishers depend on them
politicians and political activists
depend on them
today big tech doesn't just mean control
over online information
it means control over politics it means
control over news
means control over commerce
and how are they using that control well
if you've been following the events of
the past two weeks which i assume you
all have
what the big tex what the big tech
companies have been doing to breitbart
news to the new york post and to
president trump the leader of the free
world
it's quite obvious what big tech's
priorities are
and that brings me to my second
definition of big tech as it exists
today
big tech is an election stealing machine
more powerful than any other in american
history
now that may sound alarmist but having
investigated the tech giants for over
four years as senior tech reporter at
breitbart news
having researched and published a book
on the subject and having spoken to
sources and whistleblowers from facebook
google and twitter
i don't consider it an exaggeration to
say that if the technologies of silicon
valley are allowed to develop to their
fullest extent
without any oversight without any checks
and balances
that we will never have a free and fair
election ever again
if you think that's an exaggeration let
me tell you what one of my facebook
sources told me in an interview for the
book
this is his quote
the plan for polarization is to get
people to move closer to the center
we have thousands of people on the
platform who have gone from far right to
center in the past year
so we can build a model from those
people and try to make everyone else on
the right follow the same path
i'll just say that again we can build a
model from those people
and try and make everyone else on the
right follow the same path
the idea becomes even more sinister when
you start thinking about it
the first thing you have to consider is
that these tech companies know
everything about you
they know what your likes and dislikes
are they know what issues you're
interested in
they know the websites you read and the
videos you watch they know who you voted
for
they know if you're a democrat or a
republican or an undecided voter
if you so much as search google for a
recipe they know that
if you're searching for hanukkah recipes
they'll know you're probably jewish
if you're yelling about the yankees on
social media they'll know you're
probably a red sox fan
if you're visiting conservative websites
they know you're probably voting
republican
if your smartphone is on they know where
you are they know your location
they know who you work for they know who
your friends are
and what my facebook source has revealed
is that big tech also monitors how our
beliefs and behaviors
change over time and what affects that
change
they want to know the types of content
that can change our beliefs and behavior
and they want to use that to manipulate
our political opinions
it makes perfect sense when you think
about it they've done this openly for a
long time to manipulate consumer
behavior
to get us to click on an ad or to buy a
product
if you use any of these platforms for an
extended period of time you've probably
encountered the very creepy phenomenon
where you're searching for information
about a product or a service
say a new microwave and then moments
later adverts for microwaves start
appearing on your screen
why wouldn't they use that exact same
technology to change our political
opinions and our political behavior
they have every interest in doing so the
question of who holds political power
matters to these companies much as it
does to every other company
the party that's in power determines
whether they're going to get government
contracts
whether they're going to get tax breaks
and how the industry is regulated
so they have an interest in controlling
us they have an interest in controlling
our politics
and there's currently no oversight or
regulatory regime preventing them from
doing so
to understand how devastatingly
effective big text manipulation could
become
consider the feedback loop because big
tech is constantly collecting data on
each and every one of us
they can conduct tests to see what kind
of information has the biggest impact on
us
let's say they put a negative news story
about a politician in front of us
and it has no impact we don't click on
it and we don't read it
they detect no change in our behavior or
the kinds of political opinions we hold
so they put another article in front of
us and another and another
each time monitoring to see if we
actually click on it and read it
and if we go on to read others like it
eventually they will find the ones that
hold our attention and impact our
viewpoints
the system constantly improves not only
does it improve
but it becomes undetectable it's already
undetectable
what determines what appears at the top
of your facebook feed or your twitter
feed
or your google search results are the
websites and the posts that you see
there
are they there because they're popular
because they're viral are they there
because what you're interested in
or are they there because big tech wants
them to be there
because they want you to see it because
they've gathered data that tells them
it's going to have the biggest impact on
you
or that it's going to nudge your
political opinions in their desired
direction
we don't know how can we know
what we do know is that big tech openly
senses on behalf of its political allies
google for example shut down breitbart
and uses visibility on search
cutting it by 99 percent in 2020
compared to the same period in 2016 it
cut our visibility on searches for joe
biden to zero
and we discovered that by the way by
using google's own analysis tools
they didn't even care that we knew about
it
twitter another company in the middle of
the most disputed election result in
living memory
twitter is censoring the president of
the united states as he adds his
concerns about the voting process
they were doing that before the election
as well and one analysis found that
twitter's censorship of the president
cut engagement on his tweets by over 80
percent
let's look at facebook we've got
republican voters up and down the
country including here in michigan
organizing rallies to demand election
integrity
on facebook a page called stop the steel
was set up to encourage those rallies
it gained over three hundred thousand
members in less than 48 hours
facebook of course banned it that is
election interference
that is deliberate suppression of voters
deliberate suppression of news outlets
and deliberate suppression of the
president
now that would be alarming and
outrageous enough on its own
but the silver lining is that we can see
this kind of censorship
it's the invisible things that these
companies do
that i think are even more troubling
we've already covered how they can
nudge our political opinions now let's
consider how they can kill entire
political movements
and do so without being detected
one big tech concept that everyone needs
to know about is
quality scores every big tech platform
whether it's google facebook or twitter
has some version of the quality score
although they all use different names
for it i first heard about quality
scores from someone who worked at both
google and twitter
the quality score is how big tech's
algorithms determine what appears at the
top of your search results
or your twitter feed or your facebook
feed etc
it's a numerical value that goes up or
down based on what big text algorithms
consider to be indicators of quality
now in the past this score was used for
fairly benign purposes
if your website or your post contained
viruses or malware
or spam or copyrighted material well
these tech companies don't want to put
that in front of users
so they train their algorithms to
recognize that kind of content and
suppress it by signing at a very low
quality score
that meant that you know posts with
viruses would appear on the 10 000 page
of google or be eliminated altogether
fair enough but over the past four years
big tech has decided that there are a
bunch of other things that should
determine
your quality score very political things
today these algorithms are asking
questions about websites
and twitter posts and facebook posts
questions like are you posting links to
so-called authoritative news sources
like cnn
or to independent blogs and websites are
you posting misinformation
are you posting hate speech are you
challenging official narratives on covet
19
do you have an opinion about the fact
that black lives matter and antifa can
gather in public
and destroy cities without concern of
covert but you can't gather in your own
chapel
you'll have to keep those opinions to
yourself otherwise it might just lower
your quality score
on social media platforms algorithms
also analyze your network who you follow
whose content you share so the
algorithms will be asking
do you follow a bunch of accounts that
were once banned for posting hate speech
do you comment on articles that contain
so-called hate speech
if you do your quality score might be
lowered
your website might be buried in search
results as breitbart uses on google
and they won't tell you this is
happening to you of course they won't
tell you what your quality score is
you'll have to figure that out for
yourself
you might have already noticed based on
what i was saying but silicon valley's
quality score
is starting to sound indistinguishable
from china's social credit scoring
system
just as in china if you defy the values
of the ruling elite
your score will go down you will be
punished
you will be suppressed and it will all
happen silently without your knowledge
now china is a totalitarian place and
the people who want to pivot u.s foreign
policy priorities away from russia and
the
middle east and towards china i think
absolutely right to do so
but i'm always a little amused by
american politicians who think we aren't
already becoming very similar to china
yes it's true china's ruling elites are
totalitarians
and they suppress dissidents but
america's ruling elites are becoming
totalitarians and they also suppress
dissidents
and like the chinese they now have the
totalitarian technology
to help them do it
that technology becomes even scarier
when you combine it
with the fact that big tech is able to
detect entire networks of people
and entire political movements there's a
whole field of computer science called
network analysis dedicated to precisely
that
identifying groups of people with shared
interests who read similar websites who
talk about similar things and similar
political issues
have similar habits and follow similar
people on social media
and big tech is also able to detect when
information is flowing through those
networks
if there's a news story or a post or a
video that's going viral among
conservatives on the platforms
they'll know about it almost instantly
and their systems to detect virality
are only growing more sophisticated
if big tech is able to detect when a
piece of information or a cause or a
movement or a person
is starting to attract viral attention
they can shut it off
that's what they tried to do to the new
york post when it published blockbuster
stories about biden family corruption
we can take comfort in the fact that it
was not very successful in that instance
but keep in mind they don't have to tell
us that they're doing it
we may have noticed when they did it to
the post but how many other times have
they done it
we'll never know
big tech's ability to to detect virality
and silently suppress it
could not be more important if it grows
sophisticated enough
and undetectable enough big tech will
have the power
not just to suppress existing political
movements
but to anticipate and prevent the
emergence of new ones
as i said if big tech's power is allowed
to develop to its fullest extent
there is no more democracy as we know it
there are no more free and fair
elections
the political playing field will be
irrevocably tilted in their favor and
there will be no going back
the good news is there's a very simple
way to rein the tech giants in
and it's this every filter that big tech
creates
on first amendment protected speech
every single one of them
needs to be optional to the user not
only that but big tech companies should
have to prove that users opted in to
their filters
so if they make a filter on say hate
speech they should have to prove
that their users chose to switch it on
and they should always have the ability
to switch it off
the same with misinformation the same
with conspiracy theories
the same with filters designed to put
so-called authoritative news sources in
front of you
even the same with more mundane filters
like relevance and timeliness and
popularity
nothing must be left out if users want
to filter their feed solely by the most
popular websites or the most popular
users they should be allowed to do so
and if they turn a single filter on on
your behalf
or even if they try to nudge you into
turning one on i think they should be
immediately stripped of their section
230 privileges
because if you accept the standard
there's anything less than this
they will impose their filters upon you
and use that to manipulate and suppress
your opinions
the ultimate goal i believe should be an
open marketplace of filters
where any third party can design a
filter
that you can then plug into facebook
google or twitter
that would give people the maximum
amount of choice in their online
experiences
and more importantly it would completely
rob big tech of its power to shape our
opinions and our behaviors
it's very important that we do this and
also that we prevent them from banning
certain users on our behalf if we want
to filter a particular
source or a person out of our feeds we
should have the
option to do that but it shouldn't be
done on our behalf
and it's important that we end banning
for our first amendment protected speech
because the alternative is what i call
digital serfdom
serfdom is a system in which serfs own
nothing not even the place where they
live or the clothes on their back
and the landowners own everything
including the surfs
now western society has done a great
deal to constrain the power of landlords
if you own a physical store your
landlord can't simply
evict you from your property because he
doesn't like the political slogan
on your hat he'd need a court order
first and if he evicts you for such
spurious reasons you'll be able to sue
him
in the world of big tech however the
situation is much different your entire
business could be based of a facebook
page
or a youtube account or an instagram
account and that is the case for many
types of businesses these days including
independent journalists
but you don't own any of it they can
take it away whenever they want
whenever they like with no court order
with no due process
and they have done this to many people
entire livelihoods have been destroyed
overnight
sometimes for political reasons and
sometimes because a big tech company
just felt like changing their algorithms
they don't have to tell you that they're
going to change their algorithm either
they don't have to tell you that they're
going to kill your livelihood with the
push of a button
they can just do it and that's something
i think that really goes beyond
politics beyond partisan politics it's
so transparently unjust that i think you
could even get democrat voters to start
caring about it
after they're done celebrating the
latest right winger to get censored
once they've done that they might
realize that they're at the mercy of
these big tech platforms too
we all are
the world wide web was meant to liberate
us it has in fact done the opposite we
are more controlled than ever before
we are moving towards a world where
everything valuable to us
is owned by a tech company which can
take it away from us at any moment
that is what big tech is at the end of
the day
not just control over information but
control over everything
control over our elections control over
our movements and causes
control over our livelihoods and i think
the most pressing question of the moment
is
how we're going to take back that
control
thank you
[Applause]
thank you mr bakari directly following
the lecture mr bukhari will be signing
his book
upstairs and the book is called deleted
big text battle to erase the trump
movement
and seal the election we now have time
for
a few q a sessions so if you have
questions please make your way to the
microphone
thanks for coming my question is
why is big tech aligned itself against
the right wing particularly populist
right to begin with
why is the populist rights such a threat
to them
well i'd say many reasons first of all
simply the culture of silicon valley
companies is extremely left-wing and
growing more so
you have to remember they all recruit
out of college campuses that are very
different to hillsdale full of left-wing
indoctrination
uh so i think that's the most basic
reason uh but there's also you know a
very cynical reason which is that many
of these companies are deeply tied to
the democratic party
uh we did a story at breitbart a few
weeks ago about uh
facebook's uh global
content regulation manager she had some
title of that nature
um and when we looked into this person
it turns out she was formally the top
ukraine advisor to joe biden when he was
vice president
google as well hundreds of employees
went between
google and the white house and the
federal government during the obama
years
and google's chairman eric schmidt was
also appointed to a pentagon advisory
council by obama's defense department
so a lot of these companies have a
vested interest
in a democrat administration and
electing democrats
in a way that they don't with uh with
republicans
uh the other thing is i mean i often
hear this
argument that well tech companies and
all corporations should be nice to
republicans because you know republicans
are promising them tax cuts and
deregulation
but i think that's precisely why they're
not nice to republicans and
conservatives
because they don't fear them as much as
democrats they know when democrats say
they're going to regulate a company they
will follow through on that threat
which is why they so often succumb to
bullying from democrat politicians
any other questions
uh i am to remind students that you will
receive or you are eligible for extra
credit if you have a good question
eligible good questions great
questions we'll start on
this site yeah you talked about the
section 230 protections about removing
them can you explain
what those are yeah so section 230
is a law that is critical to these big
tech companies it was passed in the
1990s
and what the law essentially does is it
makes tech companies
it makes tech companies immune from
defamation lawsuits
uh related to the content that they host
so you can't sue twitter
because of a post that a twitter user
made even if that post uh violates
if it's defamatory anything like that
you can't sue twitter for that you can
only see the twitter user
and if tech companies didn't have that
protection
then they'd just be overwhelmed by all
these defamation lawsuits because they
can't control and monitor all of that
information at once
so it's a law that's very critical to
the tech companies and the argument for
reforming it is that tech companies are
behaving less like platforms that host
content
and more like publishers that you know
decide what what content puts in
is put in front of you so if the tech
companies are deciding what content is
put in front of you
it's probably fair that they should be
legally liable for that
so you can't sue a library because a
book defames you you see whoever wrote
the book
but if the uh if the library is you know
shoving the book in your face are only
stocking copies of that book then i
think you can probably make a case for
that
um i think what needs to be done with
section 230 is that
liability needs to be tied to certain
standards so platforms that want this
special legal immunity that no other
type of company
has should have to behave like platforms
simply hosting content instead of
picking and choosing what we see
on the speaker's right thank you so much
for coming um i have a question
about like the big tech company so the
reason they have so much power i'm
assuming is because they have a little
bit of a monopoly in those areas is
there any way
to deregulate the market in such a way
to make it appealing to competitors who
might be able to use these filters
and therefore eliminate some of that
power both eliminating the deadweight
loss that's created by the monopoly
but also in a non-regulatory way
allowing competitors to regulate the big
tech
market for them i don't know if that
makes sense well they they certainly are
monopolistic in a very important sense
in that if we've seen multiple examples
over the past few years where
someone tries to create a sort of free
speech competitor say twitter
or to youtube and what happens is google
and apple instantly ban whatever app it
is from their app stores
and because google and apple control 99
of all smartphone operating systems
worldwide that's essentially excluding
them from most
smartphones so they do have a very tight
show called over the market in that
sense
um i think the way to go in terms of
breaking up the big tech companies which
is what a lot of people talk about is
you've got to separate the platforms
from the filters
i think uh platforms should host content
but anyone should be allowed to
filter it so anyone should be allowed to
create a filter to filter google search
results
or to filter a facebook feed currently
it's all controlled by the uh
the companies that own those platforms
but i think that should be open to
everyone i think that will really
undermine
their power and create genuine
competition
hi as far as i'm aware some european
countries
for big tech companies they've made it
so you can purge data that those
companies have on you
do you think that'd be a viable solution
for companies such as twitter
facebook social media platforms this is
another interesting solution yes i think
if you made data portable so say if you
have a twitter account and you've got a
lot of tweets on there and you've got
people you're following
i think all of that data including the
data on who you're following and what
you've posted should be portable and
owned by you
so that twitter doesn't want you on
their platform if you or if you disagree
with twitter's policies you should be
able to take all of that and instantly
port it onto another platform
i think that would be another way to
again undermine the power of big tech
hi thank you so much for coming um so
you had mentioned that all of these big
companies
google facebook etc they use filters to
um
work out things like hate speech and
news reliability and such but that
they have it has to be proven that its
users opted in
is there a way for the general populace
to see
what these filters are and to
potentially opt out
not currently not with the vast majority
of them so
internet censorship really escalated
after donald trump one which you know
big coincidence there
but uh before that before the uptick in
censorship after 2016
uh tech companies did actually give
people optional filters so the most
obvious one is google's obscenity filter
you've got the safe search button in the
top of the top right hand corner of
google and you can turn that on or off
but they've decided not to do that with
any of the other filters they've created
and we don't know what they are
we know that they're filtering
misinformation and hate speech
and uh fake news and covered conspiracy
theories and all sorts of new categories
they've invented that keep inventing
these categories
but they don't have to tell us about all
of them they could be filtering our
feeds in ways we have no idea about
uh you mentioned that you thought bans
should not be possible for any company
what would you think in terms of
subjects like doxing where
there's thousands of users coming from
certain ip address
in order to slow down sites or spam and
for example like youtube channels or
twitch channels meant to
limit people's ability to see stuff from
companies that are
doing this where bands are the only
recourse currently
in order to prevent these issues from
happening well uh do you mention ddos
attacks
yeah well i mean that that's like
illegal activity isn't it so they
shouldn't be forced to host illegal
activity
but i think for all first amendment
protected activity
people should be able to choose what
they see or not
thanks for coming so i have a question
about how you would practically move
forward with um your suggestions of
separating the filters from the platform
and things like that do you think that's
practical for owning your own
information or do you think the
companies would just give you a copy of
that information and then just keep
collecting it on you
like do you think would your practical
steps be for moving forward well i think
i think the question of stopping them
collecting information
is uh is a different one to stopping and
censoring so they you could
theoretically have all sorts of filters
but they'd still collect information on
you
um and again if you owned all your own
data that doesn't mean that they don't
have access to it
so i think the data collection question
is uh is a different one
um it's certainly an interesting but
it's
but what i will say is that they'd be
limited in the ways in which they could
use that data
if you open up the filtering marketplace
because right now
they're able to use that data to decide
what goes in front of you what you see
on your feed whereas if the filtering
marketplace were opened up that would no
longer be the case
all right hello uh regarding illegal
activities things like you said aren't
protected by the first amendment
um i think you said that you don't think
these tech companies should be forced to
um
keep illegal content on their platforms
but should they be held liable if
something is spread through their
platforms like
all that illegal activity makes its way
to people i mean that that's a case for
that i mean i think
big tech companies have the resources to
get rid of genuinely illegal material
and that's
absolutely fine section 230 doesn't
protect that kind of material
um so yeah i think that's definitely
debatable
in other words how do we attack these
companies economically because
they in the end they're corporate
entities and they have to still make
money
they're abusing that now the related
question is is it possible to have a
negative quality score because i'm sure
uh so yeah the the two questions
gentlemen asked was uh
one how do you inflict economic damage
on these companies to sort of you know
apply uh economic pressure on them to
make them do the right thing
the second question is uh is it possible
to have a negative quality score
a 100 is possible to have a negative
quality score yeah
and uh they're constantly thinking up
new ways to lower your quality score in
fact and highly politicized ways
as far as putting economic pressure on
the on the companies the ideal of the
free market is that you know you have
consumers
who vote with their feet and companies
don't want to upset consumers so they
give consumers maximum choice uh if we
lived in that kind of world that's
probably what the companies would be
doing but we don't live in that kind of
world
i think these companies you know
consider one
their social surroundings the pressure
they're getting from their own employees
which is constant they're constantly
being pressured from below in these
companies
to censor conservatives they also have
to consider what democrats will do what
a joe biden administration might do to
these tech companies if they don't play
ball and censor his political opponents
so and that's then that will obviously
uh influence their profits as well so
they have all these other considerations
as well
um and also their own their own ideology
i mean
i think the leadership of google were
we've got that leaked tape it's pretty
clear what their ideology
is the co-founder of google said he
thought the trump election was offensive
one of their other executives said he
thought the populist movement should be
a blip in history
they were also talking about using
google's anti-extremism tools in the
context of the trump movement
so um yes there's
there's the prophet motive but there's
also as matt was talking about earlier
this
new secular religion this woke religion
and sometimes i think in the minds of
these
tech oligarchs that takes precedence
thank you so much mr bakari thank you